let's jump to the story from Fox News
Blue Jays Anthony bass booed in first
game since sharing video endorsing
Target Bud Light boycotts nice uh bass
received jeers base received years from
his home crowd
it's Toronto they boot him good
he apologized it didn't matter that
proves the point even if you say you're
sorry you'll be educated they will still
boo you so here's your warning if you
truly believe it there's no point
apologizing because it won't work wait
do you think they were booing him
because it's apologized yes the people
of Toronto are not booing him yeah
apologizing they're booing him for
saying it in the first place yeah well
because he lives in a liberal hellhole
yeah and that's probably why he
apologized in the first place he did
nothing yeah what a Canadian it's not
going to happen like no one he's he's
gonna it doesn't matter it's done so
endorsements are gonna be like oh we
want to be involved yep that's the thing
this is a religious cult that has no
path towards Redemption there's nothing
you can do to turn it around he could
have said look these are my beliefs I
stand by them and gotten support from
the religious community and the right
instead he was like I'm so sorry please
re-educate me Daddy
you know who I want to be my allies the
people who hate me and are actively
trying to destroy my life I think
they'll accept me if I say the right
thing
and they hate him on a fundamental
philosophical level he's a white man and
he's still going to kneel to them and
and then now he's lost me too because I
would have had your back homeboy but now
I don't give a damn what happens to you
exactly he's a white male athlete the
only way to left would ever like him is
if he was competing in women's sports
sure he became a yeah if he became a
woman he would dominate uh an example of
if we had social media in 1939 and we
watched people in in Germany saying yeah
I'm sorry I said that thing that I loved
the Jewish people I'm sorry and we're
like What in there the hell are they
doing that is a better example I think
with the cultural revolution watching
the struggle sessions in real time they
would take people put signs around their
neck dunce caps and then they would all
start chanting and yelling at him and
they were just like power and now we
have social media dude right that's
exactly what they did they struggle
sessioned in dude it's so creepy to
watch because he didn't believe that
apology you could tell he was reading
the script yeah I want my three my three
million for the year what did I and I
did something wrong I don't even
understand is it if I'm not mistaken he
all he did was like repost on Instagram
a video saying that protest the woke
corpse basically you know what he should
have done good for him you know if I was
him and I was in a situation in Canada
and they're gonna arrest him or
something right I would go in front of
the camera and say look I want to
apologize to all the people who have to
experience what target has in the front
of their stores and they're upset by it
and I want to say to everybody that it
is not that evil exists the problem is
that good men do nothing and I will not
be one of them get your buddy to make a
video a little short commercial of him
throwing a baseball at like the the
cardboard cutout of some ridiculous
yeah everyone on Earth
this is a guy who is having a press
conference in front of the press and he
said I am sorry I will be better
educated I will use the resources when
he should have said the all that is
needed for evil to Triumph is for good
men to do nothing and I will not be one
of those men doing nothing so no I will
not apologize because what I said was
right I think that he would have the the
people that would have had his back are
people that he doesn't know exist that's
part of the problem well this is what
Ashley was talking about is that if
we're actually upfront and honest and
loud about our opinions then he won't
feel so alone I mean it's really
partially not not the people in this
room but like probably a lot of the
people that are watching this right now
that bite their tongue all day every day
about everything they believe in so the
lunatics think that they're the majority
they're not speak tell the truth this is
an important part to that because even
if he said you know that I've had a lot
of people from these communities come
out and I understand that there's
certain things that they might perceive
as hurtful but I still don't think this
is a good thing for children I don't I
still don't think this is good for our
culture I think that there's also a lot
of value to that and he could have said
that but in a much much better position
while also validating some of the
concerns they tried to um get Kyrie
Irving maybe like half a year ago with
because he reposted a link very similar
story and you know he's just like he he
addressed it but he did not apologize
and it went away well so but Kyrie also
had sacrificed tens of millions of
dollars in salary because the vaccine
mandate in in New York this dude this
dude rides for real like he is not
playing around with his beliefs and
that's why I respect and I will rock
Kyrie jerseys wherever I go because I'm
like I want even if I disagree with you
I want people that actually like are
proud about their beliefs even if even
if it's not allowed and he sacrificed
I mean crazy amounts of money he almost
he almost gave up his entire NBA career
over it that's it's true it's amazing
it's amazing what happened and then you
have this guy who now I will just I've
already forgotten your name bro you
could have been a legend and they let
him he was on the court hugging his
friends who won a game but they wouldn't
let him play I know dude it's ridiculous
it's clearly nonsensical but it was it
was beautiful because he's so crazy
because he held that line he proved how
nonsensical it all was and that's
there's power in that well it's just
it's just garbage like the the the
managers or the coach they're like your
parent like no you can't play with him
he has bad ideas his family is really
cool you might get sick if you play with
him yeah exactly are you wearing a San
Diego Padres hat yeah that's based you
got the baseball dude I believe what you
say about I look at based bold that's
the truth let me let me pull up this uh
tweet from Robbie starboard take a look
at this he says yesterday MLB put up a
woke trans flag logo today today it's
been removed players are in full rev
volt over the issue they're sick of
being being used as political pawns for
wokeness oh hell yeah and then
apparently they put a Lou Gehrig day or
whatever today but we expect most
companies to put the flag up for the
month right they took it down already
because players are getting angry I'm
telling you we they've crossed the line
people have pointed out that Target had
this stuff in the front of their stores
for a very long time but only now are
people getting angry I'm like yeah
because y'all crossed the line with the
schools and the kids and all that stuff
and now you've caused a reverse reaction
where people were upset with you but
tolerating you now that they're doing
the weird things in schools with these
books that are explicit and gratuitous
now there's like none of it none of it
none of it and that means Major League
Baseball's got players saying uh you
know people are seeing what happens when
you give them an inch there's and I
think some people are going to say well
let's take back the whole mile except
that inch no no no there's it all back
there's a really interesting conflict
that's going to play out now because so
much of Major League Baseball's
sponsorship money has advertisers that
are deep in the ESG Dei world so they're
going to have conflict where advertisers
start to threaten them because they're
they're doing what the players union is
telling them that they must to respect
the players demands so there's going to
be a conflict between basically your
employees and the the sponsors that that
keep you operating so I don't know who's
going to win out but it's going to be
interesting to watch who makes the MLB
more money the the games the players or
the commercial well the I mean the game
doesn't exist if you don't have the
players so that's kind of foundational
right
but like could they that's a good point
would they would they do better off
firing a third of the players and then
having like a woke League that gets
Coca-Cola money or I think A League of
Their Own and it's devastating if they
were starting well here's the thing they
could put them all on steroids and just
call it gender affirming hormones right
so the games could be pumped up they
might be able to bring back the Barry
Bonds era like 1999. we're all juicing I
heard but I love it you know this is
something that I think the trans
Community not the community but just the
the political movement of the trans
movement right now you got to understand
you don't need to win this is not about
winning and losing you don't need to
push so hard all the time to win it's
about coexisting so when you've got
you've got your foot in the door now you
don't need to push it so hard it's gonna
it's it's causing friction and
diminishing returns so there's a point
where you start to work together you
fundamentally misunderstand their goals
and intentions if they want to win
Society with their ideas they're pushing
too hard but that's the mistake when
they write books where they say things
like From the Ashes of the old we shall
I'll build Anew and then you go but
we're going to coexist right they go yes
it's right Ian and then you turn around
and they start fireworks so you've
created ashes now if you if you keep the
temperature up at the same temperature
it was at when you burned everything
down you're not gonna be able to create
anything new because it's too hot but
the point is they're intentionally
corrupting and eroding culture and
they've stated that as their goal then
you come along and you're like everybody
let's work together and they go you got
it Ian let's work together you're saying
they want to turn around and they start
fire pumping buildings they want to
regrow something and at this point I
think that the seeds have been laid you
can now regrow a stable Society I I I I
really think you don't understand these
people I think I think you need to read
what they write read their books read
their strategies they literally want the
US government to completely collapse
they want parents to abandon their kids
they want kids to abandon their parents
they want it's it's not about gender
ideology that's why it's only one
component of the overarching critical oh
yeah I'm not talking to the Psychopaths
that formulated the the attempt at
Revolution I'm talking about the people
that have been part of this movement
that have been thinking they're doing
the right thing by bringing awareness to
trans people you've created a lot of
heat by pushing so hard you're being too
kind to a lot about and and when we have
someone like Sarah higdanon who clearly
doesn't agree with what the ideology is
doing you're not talking to anybody no
I'm not talking to Sarah Sarah I'm
talking about people that are like it's
good that Target puts those in the front
and they don't really I'm not talking
about the people that wrote the books
about cultural cultural Marxism or
anything like that those people are lost
to me it's these people that are like
why are they so angry we just want to
help trans kids those people like you
don't need to win it's not about winning
there's no winning in music but like
there's no such thing as a trans kid
right that's not even the point I don't
wanna I don't want to derail and get
into that whole debate the point is
there are default liberals who have no
idea what's going on and then there are
Liars who are lying about what's going
on I don't think you're talking about
anybody for them I mean sure there's
some people probably who are paying
attention and are just so Daft they
genuinely believe it's a social movement
to help people but
it's either pure exploiters who know
they're lying and you're talking to
nobody or it's default liberals who have
no idea what's going on aren't trying to
help anybody in our virtue signaling
they walk into Target and they're like
don't know don't care they're not
actually going out and campaigning being
like I want to really help these people
there's maybe a few but they're not
politically relevant it's like the
people that put the trans flag in their
bio those people I'm talking to those
people the default liberals who aren't
actually fighting though the people who
do that are like they call them armchair
activates they don't pay attention
they're not involved in politics they
don't listen to podcasts they don't
listen to the news they see their friend
do it they do it and then they walk away
that's it and then they vote for a
Democrat when you say hey you don't need
to win you're causing friction I have no
idea you're talking about dude yeah
that's the kind of that's the people I
want to wake up like but then at some
point we got to work together otherwise
we could lose the union but so so so the
issue there is you don't talk to them by
going to them and saying hey you know
that issue you know nothing about that
you posted about they're going to be a
lot I don't know what you're talking
about well if they're watching the show
tonight they know what we're talking
about respectively listen Ian they don't
want Union with you brother no they
don't want who are you say who's they
the people that live in the blue cities
that enjoy the trajectory of things
those folks are they're cultists they
want the trajectory that they're on they
don't want to they don't want to go back
to some sort of like
I have peace and prosperity period like
it just seems as if they are very
committed to seeing the degradation of
civilization and and if you are not on
board with that well then you're going
to have to find a different place to
live and that's what I did I moved from
California to Florida because I knew
that was where it was headed and there
was no option I had to go thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time